Right. And we're just going to keep doing this over and over
again. Well, Donald Trump is literally encouraging violence like
over and over again. It's insane. This insanity. Like, yeah,
people should fight back until until the other side stops. Like,
what else? Yeah. What else are you going to do? Sit there and
just keep getting over and over and over again. >> That
This is unequivocally just calling for violence, right? This
is unequivocally, yeah, civil war. Yeah, civil war. Till Donald
Trump, Civil War. Like, he's just telling people to go and do
it. He's actually just like, "Yeah, go kill people. Let's just
go. Let's go. Let's go kill people." That's crazy. I didn't I
thought he'd surely walk you back from this. Okay, so just to
be clear, there's no possible way in this entire universe that
the people who are going civility politics still associate with
this guy, right? Like Aerodite, like uh Z, like these people
have to have totally disavowed and denounced and moved on with
their with their lives and their careers, right?
One thing is guys, we were checking out what were we checking
out? We're checking out that food shop's hutch interrogation
that was going on. All right. And I kind of want to see where
that goes. Where does that end up going >> if it's black
on your end? >> We need more people. >> Got um civil
>> you over the head with the olive branch and uh >> hopefully
it gets us some sort of common ground. Uh I don't know regarding
the situation itself. I feel like we're going to get into that.
So uh I think I I'll hold off for now and let the other folks
uh do their bit. >> Okay. Well, thank you for being here.
I'm sure we will get into it. Um
Holly, now that you're here, what are your >> Okay, sorry
for the delay.
Um my thoughts are that uh extreme polarization in this country
has obviously led us to a very place. There's plenty of blame
to go around and lots of that blame deservely directed at Donald
Trump and plenty of Republican influencers and politicians who
obviously blame the type of stoastic terrorism that we're used
to seeing from our uh favorite tanky Twitch user. However, to
me, this is not the same as gerrymandering or making edgy jokes
where you have to meet what the other side is doing in order
to still be in the game. I don't see how the left or liberals
lose. >> Oh, so totally reasonable thing. Hey, we don't
have to actually match tactics here. Turns out, wait, it turns
out violence and the discount, sorry, the disavow violence, we
just have our own policies on that >> by not playing just
as dirty in this type of game. I don't see how the left or liberal
loses if they decide to turn down the rhetoric. Even if most
of the responsibility for the rhetoric falls on the other side
of the aisle, I don't see why this aspect also needs to be gamified
when we're paying a human life for it. Those are my thoughts.
>> Thank you, Dev. Welcome to the stream. What are your
thoughts? >> You're muted on your end, sir. It's time for
the streets to run red with the blood of everyone. Let's go.
How's it going, guys? I'm just looking around. Wait, what your
thoughts? >> My actual thoughts. Okay, so you know, jokes
aside, there's a pattern. Okay. When you have a leftwing guy
who attacks a rightwing guy, you'll see establishment Democrats
offer condolences. Maybe they'll take the opportunity to shell
for some new gun. >> Wait, why why won't this Oh, I see.
>> Sorry, try to slow down. >> Far leftist over on
blue sky, they'll cheer and clap and talk about how liberals
deserve the bullet, too. Right-wingers talk about wanting a civil
war, and they want they want revenge. They want justice. But
when a right-wing guy attacks a leftwing guy, you'll see establishment
Democrats call for calm. They'll definitely shell for new gun
laws. um far-left communists. They might be outraged, but they
might also say, "Lol, he was a lib. He was a traitor of the revolution."
And then, >> wait, why' they say, why did the lefty say
libs deserve bullets, too? Oh, I >> They invent these
counter was not truly rightwing. He was a crypto leftist who
was a glowy or some. And there can be no real reconciliation
unless the right deals with its own violence. And that's kind
of weird to say when it was a right-winger who just got killed,
but it is nonetheless the truth. >> And I guess we'll get
into it as to >> Yeah, we we will. Uh, and last but certainly
not least, Destiny, what are your thoughts here? Political violence
and what we do about it. >> Yeah, we have a leader right
now, the United States of America, named Donald Trump. If anybody
has a responsibility to turn down the violence, it probably should
be him, especially given that he's the one that pushes a lot
of it. Um, seeing Charlie Kirk get exploded on streamable over
and over again is exactly the type of stuff that Republicans
push for. It's ex exactly the type of stuff they want. You can
tell by the way they respond to it. It's not a call for peace.
It's a call for more and more and more violence. That violence
just always seems more acceptable when it's not happening directly
to you. Um, if you have two people standing in front of a, you
know, piece of paper dows in kerosene and both of them have a
mad >> dude. If you if you actually told me that Desi was
paid to try to get Republicans elected, I wouldn't be shocked,
right? Like that he's like actually just a very effective scop
to get Republicans elected. I think that is broadly what his
advocacy leads to. His advocacy, his voice on the internet broadly
exists to drive far more Republican votes than Democrat votes.
That is like his that is the entirety that is the basis of his
existence
>> One person extinguishing their match is not going to
prevent the paper from catching on fire. this weird game of saying
the left needs to turn it down over and over and over again.
We're like a decade into this insanity and Donald Trump even
today like people on Fox and Friends are begging him to wait.
You can you can literally say the left you you can literally
say saying the left needs to turn it down is everyone needs to
turn it down. Nobody's saying you have to say oh the left has
gone too far with the violence. Nobody's saying you have to agree
with their framing. Who said that? Who made those rules? Say
hey everybody's raising the temperature raised the temperature
way too far. We turn it down. call off the civil war that the
other side keeps screaming for and he refuses to do it. Uh Matt
Walsh from the Daily Wire and a ton of other >> Hold on.
Actually, you could even go further than that. You could say
the the temperature is way too high. Donald Trump took us there.
Donald Trump pushed the temperature this high, but everybody
needs to be responsible for lowering it. That's fine. That's
fine, too. >> We're literally calling for revenge, for
retribution, for some type of war. uh the idea that the left
shouldn't say anything or that the left needs to take lead on
this. It's civility is achieved when both sides agree to be civil.
And if the right isn't agreeing to be civil, then the left is
is being amoral or immoral by trying to be civil. You shouldn't
you shouldn't subject yourself to extinction when the right is
calling for, you know, a total destruction of your side and keeps
saying you're at >> Okay. And with that, I open up the
floor if anyone feels they're being balked over or needs to get
>> So, I would say that if you're making these arguments,
right, oh, I don't want to disavow the violence. I want pressure
on them. I don't want I don't want to disavow the violence. It's
like, okay, so you're just calling you you want more violence
then, right? Like you you literally you are acknowledging that
they're pushing for more violence and you want to match tactics.
Okay, that's that's fine. I mean, if you want to say that, but
then actually advocate for your real position. Don't do the like
hidden position. Don't do the cut like the cucked like I'm going
to try to hide my power level position.
>> Get a word in edgewise, just let me know. But other
than that, let's get to the conversation.
>> Yeah, I I'll go first. My first question for Destiny
would be, if we had a clip of Trump today saying that it needs
to be nonviolence and and kind of honoring and lifting the spirit
of Charlie Kirk and following in his footsteps, would that change
any of the analysis we're doing here? >> If Donald Trump
was making strong like disavowels of violence and saying everybody
needs to turn it down. That would be very good. It would start
to change things. Yes. >> Okay. So, I don't want to do
the the clip game back and forth, but I just, you know, you want
to take my word for it, it great. If not, we can do the clip
game. U saw a clip of him today. Uh, I don't know if it was on
the it was like on the White House lawn and I heard him explicitly
saying
>> uh I think whatever this clip is I'm pretty sure anytime
I've seen Trump say I disavow the violence. I'm pretty confident
that's been followed with but the far-left lunatics are the ones
who are driving it, right? Which is always going to be a failure
for like the the desty test which is they have to admit that
they're more wrong than we are. >> Basically the clip that
you're talking about and literally 5 seconds before the edited
clip
>> he blames radical left Democrats.
So then >> right like it's always going to be even if they
disavow if they ever imply that we're more responsible than them
then no I can't disavow no I will never be more mature than Donald
Trump I will always whatever Donald Trump sets the bar as I will
be uh as bad as him no matter what Donald Trump is America's
moral paragon America's moral light whatever Donald Trump's morals
are that's the morals all of America should have
I guess are those morals effective not for the party makeup right
Those morals won't be effective for Democrats. Democrats are
more educated. Democrats have stronger senses of morality than
Republicans do. I'm sorry. This is true. You will not win votes.
You will not amplify your base by appealing to populist to populism.
You have a choice of tactics. If you want to be populist, you
guys need to get in the trenches. Okay? You guys have to start
advocating that like there's psychotic running. All right? That's
what you need to do. actually appeal to the 60 IQ masses that
you're trying to appeal to when you say I want to go to Donald
Trump's level. If you're going to try to appeal to, oh, we should
follow the science, we should trust the science science and like
vaccines are great and all of this. If you want to do that, then
you need to act like people who are whose voters are educated,
whose voters are informed, whose voters care about stuff, right?
If you just want to do populism, then stop sucking at populism.
Actually appeal to the populist mind. And in that spirit, then
I seem to recall back to the the Biden Independence Day speech,
which I agree was not as bad as people make it seem make it out
to be because he puts this caveat in there where he's saying,
"Oh, it's not the whole Republicans. It's not the whole conservative
movement. It's just those MAGA Republicans." And seemingly putting
that caveat in there was enough to kind of quell people or I
guess get people folks on the left to think, oh, look, he's not
calling for violence. He's just it's just those crazy MAGA Republicans.
>> I watched the entire speech and I've read the transcript
and I'm going to link it to you. He's explicitly talking about
people who deny the results of the 2020 election, a belief that
over 80% of conservatives hold today. is saying he was 100% correct
in his analysis. >> And so, so you're saying there there's
a world of difference there then between Biden when he when he
clarifies and says, "Oh, I'm just talking about MAGA Republicans."
But then when Trump says, "I'm just talking about radical left
Democrats." That's you're saying that's different, those clarifications.
>> Biden was talking about people that were denying the
outcome of the election. When Donald Trump says radical left
Democrats, he's talking about every Democrat in the United States
of America. Biden explicitly said afterwards, "I don't even think
the majority of Republicans are mega Republicans." But he was
explicitly talking about people uh I think this is this guy actually
has a funny enough I think he has a good point here. that like
that's basically just going to be down to your interpretation
of the words. I think I think >> as a result of the election,
which is a view that most conservatives, a huge majority, hold
today, which that's absolutely corrosive to our >> A huge
majority of conservatives believe the election was stolen.
>> That might be true. I mean, you'd get that with Republicans.
I again, he uses the two words interchangeably even though they're
vastly different like >> This morning when Donald Trump
was asked, "What can we do? What should we do?" Donald Trump
says, "Uh, like take vengeance." And then the guy's like at the
ballot box and he's like well yeah voting but that doesn't work
anymore because it's all rigged and that was what he said. It's
like okay so I guess we're just gearing up for civil war. >> Okay.
Any Go ahead, please.
>> I guess I just like So what comes next then? So I Destiny
I really am with you that this is like to both sides this is
not an accurate portrayal of what's going on. I I I find myself
very frustrated that so many people on the right can't bring
themselves to also just deescalate. And overwhelmingly Democratic
politicians and Democratic center lib whatever influencers have
been calling this out and have and have seemed uh justifiably
horrified.
It really it kind of seems like it's only a certain segment of
the left even that is really feeding this ugly machine. But why
not denounce? I mean as I think maybe Dev pointed out on Twitter
>> I would just love So if there's a if there's a section
of the left that are feeding that ugly machine, I would want
to ask both Destiny and Tally which section is that? And is it
the same section that Donald Trump keeps railing against? Cuz
it sounds like Donald Trump saying Hassan [__] shouldn't
have a voice. And I hear that from Destiny and Arerodite and
a bunch of other people who are vaguely attached. Why is it when
Donald Trump says it he's referring to all Democrats? But when
you say it, it's like way different cuz it sounds like to a lot
of people that'll sound the same. There should be a differentiation
there. >> I don't know if we've said it in his opening,
but these are people who are like barely voting with the Democrats
anyway. They are they they want violence against the libs as
much as they want violence against you know the evil >> car
we talk about later the problem we have right now now right now right now
is the president of the United States is pushing us to civil
war why the I talk about relevant tanks don't even vote >> sure
and I agree I agree the president has a problem too but what
I hear you saying is that >> hey Destiny I just want to
kind of talk about how like you're right and I want to seek your
wisdom uh you're why would we talk about that oh you're you're
totally right about that I am a actually and um and
>> essentially like the people like you left of center
people libs also can't back down from this fight because the
other side isn't other side isn't taking their lighter. >> What
a subhuman uh >> but then so where is that going to get
us? Then they're still a fight. >> We go to civil war.
We go to Yeah, we fight. What do you mean? >> So you So
then Okay, so we're going to go ahead towards civil war. Like
what what kind of >> civil war is better than better than
extinction, right? What do you mean? What kind of a solution
is that? It's up to the other side. You can't choose to have
both people go to civility. That's not a choice that one person
can make. One person can can choose to either fight or be made
extinct. And right now, >> I just love that Destiny is
totally totally to everything Bosch has said. He has to admit
Bosch was right about everything. Bosch was his intellectual
superior in every possible way.
Right? Bosch just won completely. That's Destiny's new line.
And he'll never say it directly, but Bosch just totally owned
him in every possible way. Now, that's what if the other side
chooses to fight, those are your only options. That's all you
can do, right? >> But you say made extinct. Okay. But so
you're leaving out the again, we're doing it's it's bizarre the
analogies we're making here because we're kind of talking about
about rhetoric online and then we're also talking about actual
violence in in real life. But obviously >> Wait, wait.
What do What do you mean we're talking about rhetoric versus
actual violence? What do you think policy? Well, I'm saying when
you say we're going to when you say I'm not I'm not I'm not trying
to say that these things are entirely separate, but when you
say we're facing either we're
>> um Yeah, Puffshake. Yes. And they will all talk. Trust
me, when you when you have to make a point about how nonviolence
is a great strategy for civil rights for to to obtain like your
equal treatment in society, they'll totally suck off Martin Luther
King and Nelson Mandela and whoever the right. But when it's
talking about Republicans and or or sorry, like civility in politics,
no, no, no, no. We can't be nonviolent. We can't be the dignity
party, okay? That doesn't work. We We'll totally trust me. And
Palestinians need to be people with dignity. They need to practice
dignity politics. But us in America with Republicans, no. We
should just go to civil war. Okay. Yeah. Just go to civil war
now. >> Facing possible extinction. Do you mean that in
a literal sense? >> Eventually it'll get there. Yeah. We're
getting closer and closer. But yeah, if the if the we've played
this game over and over again, I'm sure most of you on this panel
watch me one on Pierce have the same argument a year ago where
every time something happens, the right either makes a conspiracy
theory, doesn't own their side, or they blame the left or they
want civil war. The left announces and outd just got fired for
saying that Charlie Kirk's, you know, rhetoric played into this.
He got fired from MSNBC. You break, right? And we're just going to
keep doing this over and over again. Well, Donald Trump is literally
encouraging violence like over and over again. It's insane. It's
insanity. Like, yeah, people should fight back until until the
other side stops. I mean, like what else? Yeah. What else you
going to do? Sit there and just keep getting over and over and
over again. >> Okay. So, actually, this is way stronger
than I thought. That this is unequivocally just calling for violence,
right? This is unequivocally, yeah, civil war. Yeah, civil war.
Till Donald Trump, civil war. Like, he's just telling people
to go and do it. He's actually just like, "Yeah, go kill people.
Let's just go. Let's go. Let's go kill people." That's crazy.
I didn't I thought he'd surely walk it back from this. How? Uh,
okay. So, just to be clear, there's no possible way in this entire
universe that the people who are going civility politics still
associate with this guy, right? Like Erdite, like uh Z, like
these people have to have totally disavowed and denounced and
moved on with their with their lives and their careers, right?
Like there's no possible way you stand beside this guy. There's
just no way, right? Figuratively, metaphorically, literally.
I mean, but I guess what just confuses me the most is like I
feel like the most recent arc we just went down was the liberals
need to kick out the the crazy lefties because they don't help
electorally and they go on and do crazy stuff and then they cheer
each other on. And I know you can try and announce it as oh it's
six follower blue sky accounts, but I mean are we not >> you
need to announce it, but that's not what this conversation is
about. The only reason why those people have so much like say
or sway is because of how dominant they are on social media because
the right likes to point them out all the time. >> Yeah.
I mean certainly you can you can look at the political strategy
of doing that. It is effective because when you're I mean we
can all agree and you know it's it's anger is what sells and
and whatnot but I just I feel like >> No wait no it's anger
that sells the Republican party. The Republican
>> I feel like I feel like if Dan wasn't out here running
a campaign against Assan desi be getting destroyed. Okay. This
is people are going to see this as me defending Hassan. This
this seems to me to be like infinitely more vi more openly violent
than anything Hassan was going with. Right? Like this panel is
crazy. How could you how could Elon Musk possibly be concerned
about Hassan? Well, sorry. Elon Musk is concerned about Hassan
because Hassan absolutely put his [__] his his Turk
roach into Elon's ex-wife, right? That's why that's why Elon's
concerned with Hassan. So, that's also, sorry, I'm using a bit
of a slur there, but you know, that's why Elon Elon got by Hassan.
That's why he's so But um yeah, Elon also hangs out with his
exson. Dude, he Yeah, Hassan had um had Grimes on like right
after they broke up. Yeah, Hassan had Grimes on right after they
broke up. And I think Hassan even suggested some but uh I just
this is like way more openly calling for than Hassan is. And
it's like now party is driven by spite and vitriol and hatred
more today than at any point in in my lifetime. It is is it's
just not even close to what it used to be. Like could you imagine
Donald Trump being the president after like 9/11 or something?
Or like he's incapable. He's he's not he's not effective as a
leader. He's incapable of leading. every conversation you have
with a conservative is constantly saying, "Well, he's funny.
Lol. The jokes are cool. Who cares what he says?" Like, he's
not a good leader. This is what the conservatives have wanted
the entire time. >> But I guess that's what I'm just trying
to get get towards. And like I think we can all agree, right?
It's when when we look at these crazy individuals, and yes, it's
it's anonymous six follower accounts on Blue Sky. But it's also
non-anmous larger accounts. You can you can I can pull I screenshot
them today just to see if we need to go through them. It's pretty
much everyone I saw where it's half a million million plus. And
not just Hassan. It's it's I don't know how these people get
their followings, but dishing out the same kind of rhetoric and
cheering each other >> What do you mean not just Hassan?
Wait, why? Bro, I don't Why do these people Why am I being pushed
towards this guy? I don't want to be on Hassan's side. I I actually
don't. I literally don't. But where is the rhetoric from Hassan
that's anywhere near this on this issue?
>> And do we have to go back four years, 5 years to find
it from Han? 3 years, I >> So, if that's the crowd, I think
that's a crowd that we should all agree is like a crowd that
deserves no place in the in the in the political agree with that.
They don't have a place in the political process. They're not
in Congress. They're disavowed by all of our leadership. They
don't exist except for in the in the Twitter retweets of conservatives
that are trying to make them a bigger deal than they are. >> So
then explain to me how in the day after the election when you're
on there with Brian Tyler Cohen and all the other all the other
folks that were in that call and you're specifically talking
about we need to jettison these pro palies that threw the election
for Trump which by the way if I was on the left I would piss
you off to I'd probably kill myself if that was the case. Um
if we're losing elections because these crazies think yeah do
what they're going to do. But if if that's not the fight that
the internal fight the left is trying to go through right now
is we need to kick out these pro pal crazy far left just whatever
term you want to use for it. But now it's like when it and of
course we have more to learn about the shooter, but from what
it seems it's going to be someone who is obviously not a fan
and which presumably puts them on to the left and puts them into
this category. Why? Yeah. Why are we like focusing on >> it's
the right? It's the right. It's the >> You said, did you
vote for Donald Trump on the All Three Times? >> Uh yeah.
>> Okay. Did you watch Charlie Kirk's neck explode when
the [__] blood came out after she got shot? >> Do
you accept that you voted for that?
>> Okay. Then you're delusional because there's no reason
to have this conversation. I don't know why. Why are we talking
about the radical left right now when the president of the United
States, a guy who has done violent rhetoric over and over again
who has pardoned every single person that he can that's involved
with violent crime on the right, you voted for this. This is
what you wanted. This is what you want. This is what you voted
for and this is where we are now. Why the [__] are
we talking about the far left? I don't give a [__]
about Hassan of the far left right now. The leader of the United
is some of the most optically like this might be like this is
optical smallox right here. Like this is actually going to destroy.
Like this guy is actually just an op. This guy does more to get
Republicans elected than any Republican influencer on the internet.
Like it's crazy. I How is this not clipped to high like to hell?
How is this not like the most clipped [__] that's
ever been posted online?
How the [__] are people complaining about Hassan
right now when this guy exists?
Like if you wanted his also it's so funny to me that it's also
not getting clipped that it's like he's so toxic people like
want so little to do with him that it's like not getting clipped
and it's not even getting called out like like
dude a year ago this is clipped a trillion times. Yes, exactly.
Exactly. That like people don't even take him seriously anymore.
He's literally just calling for violence. He's literally saying,
"Okay, well, you listen, vote for Trump, you get shot in the
neck. It is what it is." Like, that's so easy to roll this out
that way to to message as if it's that, right? I could almost
give like a little nuance in that. That's probably not directly
what he means, but it's exactly how you can take it is he's just
he's literally out here advocating saying, "Hey, you voted for
like Trump who who pushes violent who pushes like um who won't
ever turn the temperature down, who constantly demonizes the
other side, and if you if you wanted violence, you voted for
the right thing, and you're I I get how maybe he's trying to
say that, okay,
but he's openly
uh he literally said earlier today that Republicans should be
in fear for their safety." Yeah. This guy is the number one Republican
vote turnout guy.
Yeah, 100%. I
Dude, at this point, is it not clear that like Dan is going after
Hassan almost entirely to draw attention away from Destiny? Like
people want to go after Hassan for a clip. By the way, the number
one Hassan clip that's going around is what, 3 years old? This
is in response to Charlie Kirk being shot in the neck. This is
crazy.
>> The ex leader of the free world, I don't know what the
United States does right now, will not disavow violence. When
the people on Fox are begging him to disavow, he won't do it.
Why the [__] are we talking about Yankees? I just
I guess I just reject that we're pinning this exclusively on
one person. I think we can I think you need to understand this
is a a much broader broader problem. We can agree. We can >> Oh
my god, it's the president of the United States, man. What are
you talking
>> Sorry, I'm doing a little so I expect
we can we can agree Trump may have the biggest impact as being
the president. I'll agree with you there, but this is just such
a bigger problem than any one individual person. >> The
problem is Donald Trump. That's the problem. He's signing off
with the violence on the right. There's a reason why every seven
out of 10 of the largest protests in US history have happened
on his watch over the past 5 years of his presidency. Like it's
not a coincidence. At some point you have to wake the [__]
up and realize that the voting is not a meme. That his rhetoric
isn't a joke. That all the memes about invading Chicago and deploying
the National Guard and Hold on a second. What is this? What is
this? What is this? What is this?
It's Z. What is this? >> Apparently clip. Wait, why did
I get I got linked to clip. Okay, ogre boy. You know that you
just gave away that this is your alt account, right? Obviously.
Is it not? Obviously, you're This is 15 views, no likes.
You just sent me a tweet with 15 views and no likes. Like, this
is clearly you. Wait, I'm not in Discord. Hold on. What? What's
up? >> Are you a viewer of yours? It's a viewer of yours
or what? >> I don't know. How do you not know who whose
account that is? >> When
Ox started getting in trouble because I forget what I forget
what what streamer was DMCAing him. He started using a a sock
account to put the clips >> Oh, I don't look at Twitter
Twitter as much. I see. I see what you're saying.
>> Yeah. Lots of people do this. Lots of people do this
with the clips. Yeah. Yeah. No, you're right. You're right. You're
right. Then you embed the videos. Yeah, sure. >> What do
you mean, how am I that dumb?
>> I would have thought if for as for as much as your fingers
are in so much of the drama sphere, I would have thought for
sure you'd have known who the that >> I don't know who
it was, bro. I didn't know who it was anyway. Okay. All right.
Not Not your Are you O? This guy's O 20,000. That's who it is.
>> I'm definitely O. >> He's been caught. He's been
caught. He's been caught. Get out. Get out. He's been caught.
We found him, ladies and gentlemen. We got him. Okay. He cleverly
hid as a Hassan super fan so that he could be Destiny's propaganda
arm. Okay. For all this time. We caught you. We caught you. It's
out in the open. It's over. Okay. Apparently, this is some >> I
got the crime statistics. >> Hutch Destiny clip. Let's
check it out. >> Not Not exactly like >> I need You
need conservatives to be afraid of getting killed when they go
to events so that they look to their leadership to turn down
the temperature. The issue. >> Okay. Yeah. That's that's
literally
that that should be you're done on the internet, right?
Like if anybody if a single person online is saying that Hassan
needs to be off of a platform,
it's over right there. That needs to be everybody's out at that
point, right? That's crazy. That's nuts. Every single person
with any amount of sanity needs to go, "Oh, you know what? Let's
opt out of this. I don't want to be around this." By the way,
this guy doesn't go to events. He doesn't go. He's I don't think
this guy's ever going to an event after this, by the way. I I
don't think so. I think he's out. Techone and Asmin won't react
to this >> is right now. >> They feel like there's
any fear. >> Okay. So, when I was talking about food chops
and what she was saying, that's just accurate. That's just 100%
what these people are on. >> They're just 100% on actually
I do want violence. I do want violence so I can use the fear
of other people to pressure them to change. What will Kyla Maxwell
say in his defense? I Dude, I don't know. I pretty consistently
just sit here and I'm like, dude, there's no way that these people
there's no way that these people will will sweep for this statement,
too. But they already they they do they sweep over everything.
Like I don't know. I don't know. It's like memes. It's just memes
to everybody, I guess. I don't know, bro. I don't know. I don't
care. I'm playing video games. Okay, I'm done today. I don't
give a god. I'm It's going to be so gay if I get killed the next
two months of I'm doing all the out here. Please don't anybody
make any actual the most weak ass Oh,
I get it. The only way to stop. Okay, they I'm just I'm just
going to meme for a second. Okay, I'm just going to meme cuz
I have no evidence of this. They've got the hard drives. They've
got the proof. They've got the subpoenas. They've got my my G
drive. Okay, the only way they stop these investigations. The
only way I don't go down is like the weird freak that everybody
knows that I am is if someone takes me out. Okay,
this is just by unhinged conservative, right? That's what we're
witnessing right now. That's like what we're witnessing is he's
just going to keep saying to like get himself taken out. He doesn't
want to be put in jail. He doesn't want to deal with any of that.
That's like the most logical explanation I can think of for this
behavior.
Anything beyond that, I don't know what the explanation for the
behavior is.
>> Beaches on my side. God, if it happens, holy [__]
I'm going to make a death note before I go out to go live and
not God. It's so
it's so optics credible. >> I shout the crime statistics.
Not not exactly like >> I need you need conservatives to
be afraid of >> I just don't know. I don't know why he's
making himself a target like this. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. I figured it out. I figured it out. Uh, he must have
some invite from Aerodite. Okay. He must have some invite from
Ardite. And he's just like he's trying to figure out how he can
get out of it. And he's like, "You know what? Uh, it's a security
risk. I can't go over to your place. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, Kyle.
I'm sorry. I can't come over. I can't do this thing with you.
We can't do this un America thing. I'm I have to stay inside.
Okay. It's too dangerous. It's too dangerous. Unfuck America.
No, I can't do that anymore. I'm sorry, Kyle. You know what?
It's just too dangerous out there. What am I supposed to do?"
The Tommy Robinson tactic. You're about to get arrested for loan
fraud, so you do a bunch of crazy and then lie and say your arrest
was political. Yeah.
I don't know, man. Is this on LSF yet? I don't know. It's It's
not that old. It's uh It's like 40 minutes old. This is some
crazy [__] though. This must be So, it's on a right.
See what people are saying here. 70 comments so far. This Destiny
guy stinks. Hey, Substance. What up? I just I don't I literally
don't get it. I don't How? How? So, O is turning on Destiny.
Well, I think Ox's got a big enough thing going on that this
is probably worth keeping going, right? And it's not I don't
think I know this is going to sound crazy. I don't think O is
like directly a Destiny affiliated thing. I think he was a DJ
for a long time, grew up out of that community and is probably
realizing like a lot of people who grew up out of that community
that that community is not worth interacting with anymore. That
community is not worth um being a part of anymore. So, he's probably
just going to slowly switch over to other stuff. Yeah,
more of a Dan cell. No, he was definitely a DJer. He was definitely
a full-blown DGER at one point, but I I just don't think there's
a lot of those people left >> climbing around and calling
it the Department of War and invading Greenland Pan. At some
point, you have to wake the [__] up, maybe this is
actually not a meme. Maybe it's not funny. Maybe I should probably
rethink when I'm voting to watch people like Charlie Kirk get
assassinated on streamable. Like, it's I I don't know what it
takes to wake you guys up to it. The fact that you want to come
here and talk about tankies is just insane to me when your own
leader of the United States of America won't just simply say,
"Hey, everybody should stop >> Yeah. If you wanted to say
something real quick, go ahead. >> Yeah. Yeah, I just want
to point out that um it's probably easy to look back at at 2016
or 2020 and say that this is a recent development of Trump's,
but it's it's really not. Right. I I looked this up. I looked
at the text of this cuz I wanted to make sure I wasn't just going
off my memory. Um in August of 2016 when he was still running
against Hillary, he said I'll I'll just read it exactly. He said
Hillary wants to abolish essentially abolish the Second Amendment.
And by the way, if she gets to pick if she gets to pick her judges,
there's nothing you can do, folks. Although the Second Amendment
people, maybe there is. I don't know. Now, that sounds like a
veiled call to um Hillary if she wins the presidency. So, this
is something the Trump's been doing for a while. It's not some
>> Is wait is Dev going to identify with like anything?
Is he going to I guess it was a little more It seemed to be a
little more cryptic today, right? I just want to make it clear
when Food Chops was talking. I actually pointed this out to the
audience, right? We we pointed this out to the audience earlier
today that like you're just objectively saying you want violence.
You want them living in fear. That's the pressure you want to
apply. And that's insane, right? Yeah. I know he's super tapped
in, Porter Beller. Um, sorry. Sorry. I was reading that message.
Uh, I can't believe they made it explicit. And I think I think
it's pretty obvious from it's going to be obvious from these
arguments cuz this would have been what food shops going off
of. So, I wonder when Dev will call it out cuz Dev's got to call
it out. Dev is super against this [__]
>> Like Dev, sorry, Dev is when he starts speaking here.
I believe he called something out like this, right? >> He
said, I'll just read it exactly. He said Hillary wants to abolish
essentially abolish the Second Amendment. And by the way, if
she gets to pick if she gets to pick her judges, there's nothing
you can do, folks. Although the Second Amendment people, maybe
there is. I don't know. Now, that sounds like a veiled call to
um Hillary if she wins the presidency. So, this is something
that Trump's been doing for a while. It's not some new thing
that he has been radicalized into or the rightwing has been radicalized
into. This has always been here. It was hidden with memes and
a lot of people fell for it when it was hidden with memes, but
it's always been here. So I guess my question then is if you
think that that's the case in that Donald Trump is pushing us
on big Marty Epstein message. The only world where his prescription
works towards averting a civil war is one where conservatives
acquies to his political epistemology. The issue with that is
Destiny is not a liberal. He's a contrarian. His entire career
is oriented towards deconstruction of anything and everything
that others believe. Some people believe that is what liberalism
is. Uh can you name five policies that Destiny supports? I'm
not sure if I could. Although I could definitely name five policies
he uh
Yeah, it's um so I think he deconstructs stuff. I think I could
name five policies he probably supports as in he supported the
policies directly as they've been proposed. But like in terms
of ideological prescriptions, I'm not totally sure, but that's
kind of what liberalism is, right? Liberalism is like a a shifting
it's like an exclusionary ideology rather than a like an inclus
inclusionary ideology. It's like it's about not doing certain
things. the absence of certain behaviors. So, I think it's hard
to define liberalism as like a collection of things,
right?
Like positive policy policy prescriptions cuz liberalism could
exist like liberalism in the Middle East in terms of the policies
that get passed might be vastly like insanely different. Liberalism
in any uh what do you call it? The Richard Spencer take. Yeah,
but I think Richard Spencer is totally correct about that. Although
it's not quite the Richard Spencer take. I said it's the absence
of a few things. It's the exclusion of a few things. Richard
Spencer said it's the donut of behaviors that mean not
it's just not >> to civil war and that we really can't
deescalate
what what next what should we >> well it's not going to
be a civil war I don't I disagree with that it's not going to
be a civil war it's going to be more like Italy's years of lead
it's going to be more like Ireland's the troubles where you're
going to have like 10 years maybe 20 years of sectarian violence
that's essentially random and then things will calm down eventually
after basically the revolutionary people age out of the system
like whenever you see like it happened in Spain it happened in
Portugal Whenever you see countries go through violence like
this, it you don't really get to deescalate. You just have to
you have to work through it. >> Here you are. >> Well,
heck, it was the 60s and 70s. >> You just kind of you kind
of just wait, guys. You got to just wait for Yeah. You got to
just wait. You know, once once it gets to the violent stage,
there's nothing you can really do. You just got to wait it out.
All right. Couple people going to die. Nothing we can really
do. It's fine. It is what it is. >> It's here, right? >> Yeah.
But it wasn't as bad as the as the years of Italy. Not as bad.
>> Oh, yeah. For sure. For sure. >> Go ahead, Tally.
Please. Am I like am I just hearing a prescription then from
you Dev also of like essentially acceler accelerationism like
we it's going to get bad there's no way to deescalate. So >> we're
not accelerating. It's not accelerating like we're accelerating
it. Donald Trump's accelerating. There's nothing we can do to
stop it. You can't you can't decelerate from one side. >> Wait,
hold on. Totally crazy unhinged Sam Hyde take. Let's see. >> This
is >> Oh, Sam Hi. Oh, this is not This is a Sam Hyde show.
Oh, this is going to be unhinged. Whatever this is, this is going
to be this is going to be [__] crazy. All right.
Jesus. Okay, we're back to we're back to the panel for a little
bit. >> Yeah, that's pretty much it. Yeah, >> I actually
for a little bit. I might watch this entire thing. We'll see
how long we do this for. I might watch the entire thing. All
right,
I'll be right back though. I'm going to get some water use bathroom
real quick. >> The So, okay. So, the only option is to
fire with fire >> and hope they stop. Yeah, >> I
guess like fight in what way do you mean, Destiny? I guess >> whatever
way. I don't know. Whatever. Whatever way people want to. I What
do you mean? What do you What do you think is the solution? What
do you think would happen if the Democrats were to disavow? Tell
me what you think would happen if the Democrats were to disavow
like they've been doing for the past 10 >> Democrats, right,
they are they are disavowing. I guess like my problem is
>> I'm not saying things have gotten better. Obviously,
I'm not saying things have gotten better, but I just don't see
how like saying, well, if the right, I guess the left should
do whatever they want to. I don't see how that makes anything
better. Are you a huge like
>> Yes. Lay down.
No, because Hamas is being the everyday life of Israeli civilians,
but it's not in jeopardy, right? So, if that if all if I felt
that like literally my life was in jeopardy right now, walking
down the streets as a as a liberal or as a gay person, that might
be a different scenario. I don't feel like we're actually there
yet. >> What does it take? What city do you live >> And
I don't want to get there.
>> When Donald Trump is deploying the National Guard to
DC for crime purposes, when Donald Trump is is using the National
Guard against governor's consent in like in California, he's
sending the Marines down there. when Donald Trump is deporting
people at sometimes at random when he's invoking the Alien Enemies
act like at what point are you like hm maybe this is probably
not a good thing maybe this is kind of >> I think we can
say all of those things are not good things and that they're
unsafe and I don't know why the answer is again so we should
just be just as as violent and and disregarding of the constitution
etc as the right I don't know I don't see why >> what was
going on with the hell why did hop on hopped on out of nowhere
the >> say all of those things are not good things that
they're unseen I don't know why the answer is again so we should
just be just as as violent and and disregarding of the Constitution,
etc., as the right. I don't know. I don't see why that >> shield.
Awesome. Wait, wait. Moral shield. How many how many subs did
we get? We get some subs from the moral shilling or also guys,
we uh we tweeted tweet is pinned in the chat. Tweet is pinned
in the chat. Go do your civic duty. Retweet the tweet. Engage
with the tweet. Guy wants off the unfuck America tour so badly
he's making himself a target to do it. Wild crazy.
All right, hold on. Where are we going here? Vos was right. What
would what did Vos say? >> See, there are historical examples
of your strategy not working. Usually when fascist governments
begin to take power. >> Also, again, I'm going to say this
a million times. Stop saying fascist. Stop saying fascist. Truly
in history, there have been like three. Okay, this is like the
fascism is like this biggest intellectually outpaced.
Intellectually outpaced again.
Vos W. Vouch W. Okay. Vouch one again. Boogeyman in the universe.
Okay, stop saying f when all these fascist, bro, there have been
like less. There's been like three in all of human history. Okay,
stop saying fascist governments. Stop saying this. Okay, it is
so cringe. Jesus Christ. Genocide is imminent. Buy guns now.
Them Bosch. Thank god Bosch was there. I've said this so many
times, but like I don't even think it's a take from Destiny.
Like I think you could make this argument that it was a fascist
government. Obviously, it was a Biden government at that time.
But, um, I just think it's so funny to me that Bosch is just
like Vos is just reading from like his vibes. Vos is like actually
one step above Crystal Girl reading like the vibes of the room
and just being like, "You know what? Uh, hold on. Hold on. I'm
sensing that trans people should buy guns. I'm sensing that I
think trans people need to buy guns. The left needs to arm themselves.
It It might be that we need to do a civil war." or he's like,
"Let me consult. Let me consult the aura, the energies around
me. Okay, let me do a tarot card reading." Yes, weaponize. We
need to weaponize now. Bosch was warning people 3 years ago,
four years ago. Get your guns now before they stop you from buying
them. If Bosch hadn't warned trans people, okay, trans people
would be removed from the from the list of people who can buy
guns. All right? He just saw it. He saw it coming. He read the
future again. Amazing. It's it's the guy's undefeated. How do
you beat this guy? We should let Vosch perhaps that is how Vosch
defines the future. Okay. Is his his attraction to lolly pictures
at this point. You know, he's a white hat lollycon. All right.
White hat lollycon. Give him the pictures. Let him let him read
the future cuz this guy can see what's coming. He's seeing it
coming down the pipe. Oh, Captain Windland. It's not just vibes.
He's obviously doing this off of his ideological beliefs and
and his like assumption of human behavior. It's not just vibes.
It's not that alone. But I mean, that's what people who actually
do tarot readings and do too, right? I'm just wait. Why doesn't
food shops possess this ability? Uh cuz Vos is a unique he's
a unique mutant. Okay. Never before seen by humankind. Never
never to be replicated. I Dude, that's that's an awesome clip.
Thank you for whoever found the time stamp. Cap. It wasn't Captain,
right? Who was Who found this time stamp? Who found this time
stamp? Thank you to whoever found this time stamp. It's a good
one. Massive W. >> Alternative is just it's just extension.
>> That again just feels like just extreme hyperbole to
me. >> What do you mean? What part is extreme
>> Uh, have I watched Vos's opinions since the shooting?
No, Nick. Why don't we watch Well, this is fun and this is like
we're watching for content, right? We're not watching for like
to get people's like sincere political opinions. If I want to
do that, I'll do that off stream and then I'll watch the actual
content elsewhere, right? This is like what's meant to be entertaining.
This is entertaining because you have a with like very little
attachment left to being politically sane just saying insane
watching him like spiral out of control. The Vos stuff I watch.
Does Vos even still stream? Yeah, Vos gets good numbers when
he streams. I do watch Vos stuff though. I watch Vos all the
time unironically. I I watch Vos videos come up in my algo all
the time. I'm not joking. They do.
Um mostly because
I just want like a lefty take on things. I watch I watch Vos
for the lefty take. I'll watch other people for a righty take.
I'm Wait, Nick, you understand what I'm saying? Vos was right
like years ago, right? Vos might be Vos to my mortal eyes will
seem incorrect right now. I'll probably disagree with Vos a lot,
right? To me as a mortal, as somebody who can't see the future,
Extreme Dad is just mad because we know 5 years from now, Extreme
Dad gets arrested for [__] a kid. Okay, we didn't
realize it, but Bosch was right about him, too. It's just going
to be a decade from when Bosch said it. Okay, I'm just I That's
how it is. Extreme dad. This guy sees the future. Your future's
been divined. There's nothing you can do. Okay? I wish you could
stop it, but you can't stop it now. All right? It has been divined.
It will happen. It will come to pass.
That's just how it is, man. I don't know what to tell you. But
I will say, you can't be punished yet. You haven't the kid. Okay?
You haven't [__] the kid, but Bosch said it would
happen and it will. All right? Just like everything else Vosch
says
driving more violence or not. >> He doesn't think that
this is going to end. Yes, he is. He he his his rhetoric >> Trump
is driving extreme violence. Trump will never disavow violence
on his side. the opposite of that. He's actually pardoned every
single person he could that's been involved in violence on his
side, right? >> Every single person's >> uh probably
not. Uh did he pardon the uh the guy who shot those Dem politicians?
Did he pardon the guy who burned down Josh Shapiro's house? Did
he pardon any of the any of the people that you use as examples
of violence? Did he pardon any of them? >> Probably a stretch,
but certain >> Wait, did the guy die? The guy probably
got actually the guy from Minnesota, right? Minnesota guy got
probably. I can't even remember now off the top of my head. all
the day sixers at least and the people that were convicted of
sicious conspiracy and everybody involved in his campaigns that
have lied on his behalf and helped >> not I'm not it's
not a point that I'm trying to fight. >> Okay, so he's
done that. He continues to signal to people that violence is
okay. He's talked about using the military to go to cities whether
the governors or the mayors like it or not. Uh >> we're
going to do list mode. We're in list mode of things like vaguely
related. The thing with list mode, okay, when he does list mode,
you actually need to slow it down and analyze each thing in a
vacuum as he lists them because when he does the list mode,
>> he he's usually doing things that don't really make
sense. >> So, he's done that. He continues to signal to
people that violence is okay. He's talked about using the military
to go to cities, whether the governors or the mayors like it
or not. >> So, he's talked about deploying the National
Guard probably with regards to riots or immigration, right? It
is not to go and like Democrats as far as I know, right? It's
not to engage in political violence or or explicitly political
violence. That's not really a good example, but he's going to
do the list thing where he'll pretend he has a really good example
and he'll list like a bunch of stuff and probably most of those
things don't really like line up,
>> Um like like at what point do we like wait for the soldiers
to start shooting and they're like, "Wow, guys, I think maybe
maybe telling people to bring the temperature down, you know?"
Oh, maybe he's implying that you'll send the the armies to those
cities and they will start shooting Democrats, I guess, is what
he's implying here. >> Maybe that wasn't enough. >> So
then if >> I thought he had a bunch of stuff, I thought
he's going to be listing things. >> Fight or extinction
that you're saying this is the left the only two options on the
left right now. I guess it's direct question. Is someone justified
in >> I'm not going to we're not going to do fed. I'm not
fed posting right here. We're not doing that. >> Huh. Thank
god Destiny needed 24 hours and just to be left alone with his
own thoughts and he started fed posting. Okay. He got an email
from Kyla saying, "Hey, can you come to this event at this time?
Hey, it's my birthday in 3 weeks." And Destiny's like, "You know
what? Actually, kill every Republican
and make sure I can't leave my house right now." That's what
that's that's Destiny's response. Okay. Hey, here's invitation
to my birthday party. Ah, kill every Republican now.
Incredible. Incredible stuff. >> But if we were on a different
platform, maybe we could do a little bit of I already got like
20 FBI agents. I already got 20 FBI agents watching all my all
the time. So, >> wiki is muted. not saying anything. >> It's
hard to have this conversation without at least
at least in a video game or hyperbolically or something discussing
this. And I understand we don't want to pet Fed post.
>> He's not even Hold on. He's he's given you everything
you need to understand. This guy didn't want to say it directly
for Destiny, but Destiny is saying the whole thing, right?
100% he's saying the whole thing. He's saying, "Yeah, you should.
You I want these people to be scared. I want violence to be used.
I like this. It's crazy, but it's what he's doing." >> Question.
Real question. Hold on. for Jenzi attorney. Do you recognize
that Donald Trump's statements today like increase the chances
of me getting murdered at the next event that I do? >> Are
we saying is he concerned about that or does he want that to
happen? Uh we can keep going. Oh, what's up Milo?
>> Based on his
dis he was asked by on like multiple times on Fox and Friends,
they asked him, "Will you tell people on the right who want revenge
that they shouldn't do that?" He wouldn't he wouldn't say no.
He said the opposite. He said, "Well, we could fight at the ballot
box, but all the voting is rigged." So, you acknowledge that
Donald Trump is saying things right now that directly lead to
an increased chance of me
being in the next video for my next
>> I would I would probably agree too, but is it more so
of an impact than a guy picking up a gun and going Charlie Kirk
at a public at a public event? Like, what what's what's more
weighing in on that equation?
>> I don't know how it's relevant. I don't know if we can
control every single individual person necessarily, but the the
president of the United States is the one driving the rhetoric
right now for political assassinations.
And it's it's right now 100% purely responsive and reactionary
to the fact that someone took a gun and went and Charlie Kirk
at at a public space at at a college. >> It's not right
now. It's been since the quote that Dev had came from I think
that was was that before he was even elected or was it right
after he was >> Yeah. But to to to finish >> it was
August 2016. August 2016. >> Okay. So, how are you asking
me? We should turn down the rhetoric when there is a guy on all
major media right now who's the president of my country who is
saying things that is increasing the likelihood of being assassinated
because your your response to it increases the likelihood that
you'll be assassinated as well. Right. and you lead into the
narative. I I think it does.
>> Not enough yet, guys. We got to we got to get those
numbers up. Apparently, Destiny wants those numbers brought up.
Wonder if it has anything to do with those FBI agents watching.
>> If I may, so when you give a reality to a lot of the
right-wingers who say the leftists just want to fight us, the
left just wants to go to war with us, the left are hunting us.
And when you come on stream and you play into that rhetoric and
saying, "I'm not going to apologize. I'm not going to deescalate."
And you know what? Maybe there is no other option than going
to civil war or something. Maybe we got to do what we got to
do. What you were doing is you were justifying and you are feeding
into their paranoid uh schizophrenia basically. And it makes
it's they have a whole media apparatus that is designed to highlight
insane takes on the left. Half the [__] that gets
clipped in mine and spotlighted is like a two second cut from
any they say. Half the people forget Uh-huh. That's the only
way you could think that's wrong. Okay. Is if you only have a
two second clip, guys. There's no way you could think it's insane
for him to say the things he does and listen to the whole the
whole speech. Okay, it's not possible. >> Don't even think
about me. Look at them trying to click [__] the Gen
Z attorney guy just did it right here talking about Biden's speech.
These are like the most docile people when you listen to people
like when you listen to the right talk about I just watched a
video of a on Facebook. The right is talking about the violent
rhetoric of Chuck Schumer of Kla Harris of Joe Biden. These are
like the most Are you ser? These are the go-tos because they're
saying things like our nation is in chaos. Give me a break. If
you want to go after Dude, it's so easy. If you want to go after
these people, if you want to do the same thing, then attack their
takes, even their takes that are sane, and make them seem insane.
That's a totally that's a tactic that I'm I'm feel like you've
totally opened up. You've enabled it. It's okay, right? But what
is not equivalent to what they're doing, even though the fight
fight whatever like violent or borderline viol violent rhetoric
you think they're doing, is not equivalent to saying, "Yeah,
I'm not going to disavow that shooter because I want these people
scared." >> It's not the same. It's just a totally different
class of of rhetoric. Like these will find anything they can
to spotlight. They're trying to make it seem like there's some
genocidal intent on the left and then meanwhile the left has
to dismount over and over and over and over and over again and
the president does nothing. So >> didn't didn't John Roberts
have to come out and explicitly call out Chuck Schumer by name
for his comments directed at Supreme Court like 5 years >> I
don't know what was his comment. What did he say about it? >> It
was like it was something about like the Supreme Court will weep
the whirlwind something something like that. Um we could we could
get the direct quote if someone wants to get it. But the John
Roberts who John Roberts is like the most tries to be neutral
fair to everybody processes everything guy. There's a lot of
a lot of people on the right hate the way he is chiefs is chief
justice over the court for him to come out and expressly condemn
uh the Senate I think the time Senate majority leader for his
commentary because it was because Chuck Schumer said that the
Supreme Court would reap the whirlwind. >> I'll get the
quote >> I guess the quote goes. >> Yeah. He said
I want to tell you uh is it Gorch Gorch? I don't know how Gorsuch
>> Gorsuch I want to tell you Kavanagh you have released
the world when you will pay the price. You don't know what you
you won't know what hit you if you go forward with these awful
decisions. That's what he said.
If if that's our standard for violent rhetoric, do you acknowledge
honestly that on the conservative side I could find that a thousand
times over? >> Yeah. No, I'm not going to die. Here's the
thing. I'm not going to >> answer to that then I'm not
even going to I can't even hear Chuck Schumer then. It's noise
at that point. It's the overwhelming amount is coming from the
conserv why would I even say anything about that comment by Schumer
if that's the standard that we're going to go by. >> So
it's just so it's just the left and Democrats are just infinitely
shielded then because you can always find a counter example on
the right. >> They're not infinitely shielded. It's just
not relevant to the overall conversation. What did Schumer say
the day after? Quote, "I should not have used the words I used
yesterday. They did not come out the way in. Can you find me
a single example of Donald Trump apologizing for anything he
has said that ratches up the violent rhetoric ever? One example
ever. I I can't put the Donald Trump, but the example I keep
hearing brought up is the Minnesota state lawmakers and how the
main person that was making making fun making jokes was Mike
Lee, Senator from Utah. And >> and Donald Trump said disgusting
comments as well. Yeah. >> About Mike Walls though or Tim
Walls, >> In regards to the Yeah. the Senate shooting.
Yeah. When I when I was looking up, all I could see was basically
him saying I didn't he didn't call Tim Walls, but that that keeps
being the reason I bring this up is because that keeps getting
brought that keeps getting brought up as basically exhibit A
of recent politically targeted violence, which certainly again
I'm not going to dispute the guy was a right-winger and he attacked
leftwinger. But the only evidence example that we're pointing
to of like elected official that was making a joke was a senator,
which is bad. I'm not going to agree with it. But then he walked
it back the next day. So just by the standard you just laid out,
if someone walks it back the next day, then it's all hunky dory.
We're cool. Did Mike Lee walk that comment back? >> He
did. >> I think he did actually. Yeah. >> Okay. He
He might have So, he might have walked that comment back, but
I would argue that Schumer and Mike Lee's comments were far different.
Do you think that Schumer had a like malicious or violent intent
when he said, "You'll um you'll pay for this or whatever?" >> Probably
not. No. >> Do you think that Mike Lee's intent was a little
bit more sinister or jokey when he's doing a nightmare on Wall
Street? when when senators get >> I think that he's necessarily
advocating for violence, but >> I Yeah, I think him turning
it into trying to turn it into an attack on Tim Walls was certainly
>> Wait, Nick, how do you explain Wait, Nick, how do you
explain the actual clip from today? The clip from today is avowing
violence directly like obviously. So,
I don't know. You'd have to be a [__] to think otherwise.
>> Ill advised. I don't see if if there's a joke on this
directly making fun of me. Let me go back and quote the quote
was a picture of the shooter in the mask. >> Oh, no. You're
talking about Destiny >> saying what? Nightmare on Wall
Street.
>> Okay. So, so
an attack on the people and the victims. It's trying to make
a political attack, an ill-advised, illtime political attack.
But you can still see it's it's still a difference in kind there
though, right? >> Did also I want to quote, did Mike Lee
walk it back or did he just delete his >> He deleted it.
He put out an official statement through his office um saying
I could find the official quote, but it was wrong. Okay, while
we find that though, um here uh Destiny with the things that
you've said, >> there's just no reason to I think like
the the way you get through this is is just you have to disavow
the violence. I think
especially as anybody with a platform, you you just have to disavow.
It's [__] It gets crazy. And and using as a pretext
for not disavowing it the fact that Donald Trump exists, I think
is also just insane. >> I feel far more extreme than what
even you were tweeting about. Um let me ask you this. Do you
think that telling people that hey gang >> Okay. Yeah,
in response to most of the Trump and most of the right calling
for war. Okay, then. Okay, that's fine. But I want these guys
on the front lines. Okay, I want these guys pulling up their
guns and doing the shooting. Like, if you're going to advocate
for this and you're not willing to go grab one of those rifles,
you got a bunch of them right there. Go to the house. Okay, hold
on. No, I need to pull it back a little bit. Okay, go do what
you want to do. Go do the thing you're advocating for. Don't
sit here and go, "Oh, we should do this. We have to do this."
Go [__] be the person you you are trying to get other
people to be. Okay? Don't be a don't be a loser. Go do what you're
advocating for because otherwise you're just made. Be the whole
[__] Don't be half the b. >> There are uh there's
really nothing >> obviously totally disavow that. Don't
want that to happen, right? Don't want any of that to happen.
But you can't you shouldn't sit here and advocate for violence
like a little
right. Go do it. >> Can do. We can't deescalate. The right
and Trump are out to get you and they want to bring us to civil
war. And then let's say tomorrow someone picks up a gun and goes
out and tries to Trump again. Do you not feel at least somewhat
that you have been responsible for that? would be feel responsible
for someone doing that maybe but like let's back up for one second
okay and not be the like I don't want to say delusional is anything
that you just said leading to that are any of those statements
incorrect is Trump basically coming after people is Trump basically
advocating not
if we deescalate we're going to be led to extinction okay so
you think that you think the left can deescalate right now right now
yes absolutely I think the left can at least on their part turn
the temperature down in such a way that we are more likely to
take control back of the house and the senate in 26 and also
win in 2028 electorally because remember there's more than just
two players to this prisoners dilemma's game there are other
factors involved including a whole host of people who are watching
what we do and judging accordingly and I feel that if we do deescalate
and the right does that those other players, the electorate,
will give us the W. Really? Did that happen last year? No, but
it happened. It happened quite 18. Like I Yeah, sure. And in
2020, um, first of all, you don't agree with that because I don't
know why you're saying I agree with that. Okay. Um, the fact
that Donald Trump engaged in the way that he did in 2020 didn't
make a single adjust and then won the election shows something
that's fundamentally broken in our me or this idea that one side
can deescalate. I I just don't think that I don't think that's
ever been true at any point in human history. I don't think it's
been true in our recent history. I don't understand where this
idea that if one like I feel like the left is
>> uh civil rights, right? civil rights literally just
civil rights largely been deescalating, right? The the peak bad
was probably I guess like the BLM riots um which which Biden
and had to disavow. >> CH stuff that was peak bad. Chaz
was pretty [__] bad. >> Chaz was bad, but I
say like the BLM RL is like larger on the national stage or whatever.
Um the CH stuff was cringe, but like Donald Trump and the Republicans
have just gone higher and higher and higher and higher and higher.
They show no indication whatsoever of turning anything down.
Every single right leaning piece of violence gets blamed on the
left anyway. So, if they keep ratching it up and more right-wing
violence happens, they're just going to say it was caused by
a leftist
>> Yep. I mean, like, whenever I talk to my my right-wing
friends who are solidly in the right-wing bubble, like people
who are decent that if you broke them out of that media sphere,
they would, you know, the the scales would fall from their eyes,
but they're still in it. Whenever I talk to them, their view
is always that, oh, it was actually a leftist who did that last
attack. It was actually a leftist who did that. It's actually
the deep state. It's a glowy. And it's like, well, even if the
left stopped doing violence, they'd be blamed for the violence
anyway. >> So, you you can't you can't deescalate in that
media environment. It doesn't work. However, the the reason that
they say and and this has been done with the Charlie Kirk stuff,
uh I think Shuan Head said, right, even if it turns out that
the killer was some kind of groper guy, right, and not really
a leftist or some kind of skitso that didn't have an that had
an incoherent political ideology, they will see the celebrations
of many on the left, right? And it's it's a lot, right? And in
people who were making memes, making jokes, going out. Um, Deb
was saying that he's got friends on the right and that if they
were pulled out of the media media ecosystem, if they weren't
in the echo chamber, they wouldn't constantly think that it's
all uh like scops or all, you know,
leftist or sorry, all like um lefties masquerading scops, false
flags. They wouldn't think all that, right? That's what he's
saying. >> Just but but they're in that they're in that
media ecosystem. So even the things that are clearly like right-wing
on leftwing violence, they think is all like leftwing violence
being propagated against leftwingers. >> Saying crazy and
then they'll see Destiny come on and say, "Well, we can't deescalate.
We might as well prep for war gang cuz otherwise we're going
to go extinct." And they're going to use that to justify to normies
that we're right and they're wrong. >> Dude, imagine imagine
nuking Japan. And Japan goes, "That's really bad. We can't we
can't surrender. These people will kill us." And and the America
goes, "Well,
they uh guys,
they uh they they aren't deescalating. We have to We have to
kill them now. We have to We have to nuke more. It's like somebody
on the left
pretty obviously on the left committed the shooting. I I'm not
100% like listen I don't think that's I think I think it's like
a 90 80 90 90% chance right now. Maybe 80% chance right now that
the shooter was a lefty guy. And it's obviously the victim is
a right-wing guy. I don't see how you could say okay well we're
not going to we're not going to disavow or disavow the violence.
It's like it's we need I guess we have to wait for it to be a
clearly politically motivated shooting and then and then people
will disavow. I just I I don't get it. I don't get I don't get
like why you can't just say violence is bad when it when it seems
when it appears that it's your side that's committed the violence.
You're like, "Oh, well, no, they pushed us here." It just seems
crazy. It seems like you just Yeah. It's just the most the most
monetarily beneficial the the highest growth tactic is just to
be the most unhinged person. So, >> and I think that if
we take out as much as we can of that equation, right, I think
that we have a much better chance at getting to a civil society.
>> Works crackpipe. Do you think Mike Walsh watched my
stream before he made his call to arms decision that the Daily
Wire retweeted? Do you think that Donald Trump watched my stream
before he went on Fox and Friends this morning when they were
begging him for a shred of humanity to call down the violence
and he refused to do so? >> Do you not think you have any
influence on these things? Because it it they don't hear from
you directly, but they hear indirectly. It's called it's called
u um it's it's uh for the lawyer guy here we call it pretextual.
They have the conclusion that they want and they will find anybody
to justify it. They want violence and they're going to say the
left if it's not me they'll find some random Twitter account.
If it's some random Twitter account they'll find some random
blue sky account. They they do this even with irrelevant. What
was the Sydney Sweeney [__] where all the right lane
people like oh my god nothing you do matters guys. They're going
to blame it on you anyway. Just kill them. Just kill them. It
doesn't matter. They'll they'll blame you for violence. They'll
find somebody to blame you for violence. Like they'll find a
Twitter account that they'll it's already civil war. Just keep
going. Just escalate. Escalate, escalate, escalate, escalate,
escalate, escalate, escalate.
Severely game theory pill right now. No, hold on. Just to be
clear, this is the worst option in game theory as well. This
is the This is a option in game theory as well. If you actually
think this is the case, you covertly build up and attack people
later. If you actually think this is the case is also it's just
telegraphing that you want to go to war, that you're actually
really mad at that side. you want to go to war >> instead
of actually building up your army and then getting ready to go
to war. It's one thing to hear childless young adults in their
early 20s talk about accelerating towards a violent conflict.
It's more difficult to understand how a father such as Destiny
could so glibly stay the course stay this course campaigning
for civil war. Um he hasn't got a lot to live for. He doesn't
have a lot of connections. He doesn't he clearly doesn't feel
any connection to his own son. Yeah. It's it's obvious like it's
obvious he doesn't right. Yeah. Anyway, >> the letter is
freaking out about this. And meanwhile, no one of the lucky people
[__] cared. They could fabricate whatever issue they
want. Today, I just learned that it was apparently 25 million
illegal immigrants that came in. When I thought it was 20 and
15 and 10, and who knows what the investment is up to now, and
now the stock market matters, and it didn't matter before when
it was going down. Like, every single thing that conservatives
are doing are just putting this false reality in front of the
eyes of of their constituents. And you're saying, "Well, if we
just turn the temperature down, these guys can't even perceive
a temperature. How could we turn it down? How would that even
matter? It hasn't helped at all so far." >> Because I'm
not >> These people these people are disgusting, too. Yeah.
every every single one of these people on the right who's talking
about like a civil war or a battlecry or whatever the rallying.
Oh, they don't know what they've unleashed. Yeah, they're all
cringe lararpers. They're all cringe loser larpers. Honestly,
should be like a should be like at least a temp ban from it should
be a permanent demonetization from from like Twitter and trying
to like take take money away from all of these people, right?
Like get it get it out of all of their hands. >> Appeal
to those crazies. I'm trying to appeal to the normie electorate
which does make judgments based on these things based on the
signal to noise ratio, right? Hey, when the signal to noise ratio
is uh mostly noise, then a lot of them just disregard it. I don't
think the Sydney Sweeney thing had a crazy about half the country
right now. >> I disagree. I I do not agree. Donald Trump
won the popular vote in the last election after trying to insurrect
the government. Not everyone who voted for Trump is part of this
crazy cohort, though. There is a significant group within the
Trump voters, the MAGA cultist that you will never reach and
I agree with you are these crazy cultists. But to say that it
is even that is most or all of Trump voters in 2024, I I I just
heard >> then it's just as bad, but it's on the other end
of the coin where they just don't care about it then, in which
case it doesn't matter anyway. >> Uh he he cites tit for
tat a lot of the time. Marty Epstein, he does. >> It's
not that they don't care, it's that they care also about what
the left is doing. And I agree with you that there has been >> misrepresent
what the left is doing. They care about the right is saying the
left is doing. Please correct yourself. Nobody here is going
to you're not fighting left lawmakers that are doing like this.
Like simultaneously the like I swear to God I've probably heard
you make these complaints on these on these on these platforms
where people are like what's wrong with the left? They're feckless.
They don't do anything. They're politically ineffective. They
won't stand up. They all they do is they hold up signs in Congress.
And then the next day when Donald Trump, the Republicans say
something different, it's like oh my god the left is calling
for violence ever. They're crazy. They're doing the most funny
[__] ever. And then tomorrow it's going to be, man,
the left is so weak and and losers. They don't do anything ever.
Like, it's whatever the Republicans tell us we're supposed to
feel about the left that day is what we end up feeling about
the left that day. Why don't we look at what the actual thought
leaders, what the actual elected politicians say and do rather
than than what Twitter is telling us. >> Stephen, this
is I think this is the game that gets played though, where it's
>> you see, I I pointed this out. Anytime anytime that
you want to argue, oh, no, no, just look at the the leaders.
It's just like the It's because you don't want to deal with like
people criticizing you or actual criticisms of you like every
time. >> Okay, it's easy and I I'll give credit to all
the Democrats who've come out and said, "Yes, political violence
is bad." Okay, you get your props for that. But right now is
about the easiest time for someone on the left to come out and
say that cuz guess what? If you don't say that, you're seen as
the one that that's fostering and promagating this type of violence.
It'd be like taking any sort of attack that the left may do or
um the right may do on the left and now all of a sudden the entire
discourse is about how the left needs to tone down the re rhetoric.
So less right-wingers go after hunting lefties. >> Yeah.
I I if the environment right now has so many huge figures on
the right calling for civil war, why the would I look to the
left to disavow people on >> So I mean and I guess I disagree
with Hey, you don't have to disavow individual people. Although
you could you just say I like obviously disavow the violence.
You're like an influencer. You influence people. Isn't this his
argument? Oh, you're an influencer. What do you think it means
to be an influencer? You influence people. Why are you why are
you arguing that >> with this framing too as far as like
yes I I see the call the calls for war? It's time to fight back.
But honestly, I don't even know what that means. I I'd love some
for someone to explain to me war against who? What does war even
look like? Is that really is this are these genuine calls for
violence calls for war? Or is this just more laring cosplaying
saying it's time to fight? You know, fight fight fight. Was Trump
saying fight after getting shot? Was that him saying okay now
it's time to to go to war? It's time to literally fight. I I
I just without identifying, you know, we're getting into some
legal ideas here. Without identifying with specificity who's
being referred to, who's being talked about, it's you, I'm sure
you're familiar, the incitement test in Brandenburg. It's without
being able to specifically define a specific call to action at
with imminence as well. Eminence of this person needs to be fought,
needs to be thrown out, need XYZ needs to be done to them. There's
so many elements at play here that are at play for a reason in
court of law because they matter if we're going to try and prove
this stuff. But we're just kind of playing real fast and loose
with, okay, if someone says it's time to go to war against far-left
communist radical lefts, and then it's like I just I've not seen
enough specificity or >> Yeah, this is this is the game
in real time. I don't think you even believe anything you just
said. I think you know that you're playing a game right now because
we have no problem trying to parse through the statements of
every random word that uh that that Joe Biden >> I just
want people to pick one standard. Like if you have a standard,
you should you should decide what your standard is for what you
think is incitement of violence and you stick to that standard
all the time. I think Brandenburg's good cuz it comports with
the law. But if you want to pick a different standard, you need
to apply that standard evenly. It just seems like every single
person, right? Every single person picks a different standard
depending on who they're actually applying it to, right? and
and it just gets like really cringe and annoying and it's just
for whatever argument you're doing right at that exact moment
in time. Yeah, latigious. So, I think I think Brandenburgg fits
nicely because it comports with the law. But if you want to say
that here's here's my standard for how I think influencers should
speak with regards to violent rhetoric, that's fine. But everybody
constantly changes how specific or how imminent it needs to be.
if they change the line constantly and there's just no solid
discernment of like what is good or what is bad in terms of like
a violent or possibly violent rhetoric cuz like realistically
with the Hassan stuff that's going around I don't see any like
actual reasonable person who would say that that uh that clip
about it's like
it's reckless but it is not him actually trying to incite violence
on anybody. It's him talking about like in a debate stop letting
these people get away from you or something in a conversation
stop letting these people get away from you. I so like that one
is not something but is it reckless to ever talk about you you
know you doing physical violence using like a medical a metaphor
of physical violence for like I guess rhetorical violence
I don't know I don't know man TSA Fuentes is that who you're
saying Hassan is that's funny almost like he's being clipped
out of context well it was but I'm saying that there's other
stuff where Hassan has directly incited violence like I think
he did directly incite violence against Tom Cotton I think that's
true but then that's like a tweet and It's like a little less
obvious. It's like not a direct method. That one is far worse
though. That's easily That's way worse. You seen Elon Musk basically
directly asking for violence at that Tommy Robinson Robinson
rally? Nope. Also was justified. Is that because it was a black
person? Hershel Walker Queenman. That's why you think it was
justified? Oh no, the Tom Cotton thing. It doesn't matter if
it's justified with the Tom Cotton thing. You don't get to do
an eye for an eye. That's not how uh the real world works. Or
at least that's not how liberal democracy works. If you want
to do an eye for an eye, that's stupid. You should never advocate
for an eye for an eye either. It just makes you look brain damaged.
Makes you look like subhuman. At at minimum, say send one of
ours to the uh send one of one of ours to the hospital, we send
one of yours to the morg, right? You escalate massively. You
never you never just do an eye for an eye and eye for an eye
is stupid.
Or we can remember these specific quotes about you'll reap the
whirlwind that Schumer says and apologizes for the next day.
But now when it comes time for people like Mike Walsh to say
we're done talking, we're done. We No, if you want to talk about
game theory, you you escalate massively,
right? If you want to if you want to talk about game theory,
you ma you massively escalate. You don't ever do like, oh, I
should do like one, you know, unhinged call to violence with
another. Yeah, I I disagree.
I guess, sorry, I'm talking about in terms of your real intent.
I don't think you saw him wanted Tom Tom Cotton killed. I think
he was just like expressing a >> Tried polite discourse
and >> he wanted Tom Cotton.
I don't think that was the way. >> It didn't work. Now
we're going to fight. Now, uh, now we're now we have no idea
what that means. Now it's well, who knows? These are vague calls.
And, you >> what elected position does Matt Walsh
>> He's one of the largest alternative media figures on
the right. >> Okay. But you are one of the largest uh media
figures on the left. You are. >> I'm an alternative media
figure. Number one. Number two, >> you just said Matt Walsh
was an alternative media figure, too. Sure. I don't have a direct
connection to the president like the Daily Wire does. Do you
think I'm endorsed by the DNC or by the Democrats? But number
two,
>> oh, you almost were. You You literally were doing interviews
of their possible chairman, right? You're getting close. >> Here's
a key difference because if you wanted to make his equivalent,
that's fine. The difference between me and Walsh right now is
I would say, "Hey, if we should turn down the temperature, I
100% would disavow both sides." He will never say that. Do you
acknowledge that? That he will never admit that there any is
any violence on his side that needs to be toned down. >> That's
why he's a liar. We shouldn't we shouldn't base our behavior
on how he behaves. We shouldn't take our morals from that base
your behavior on how he def when if if somebody self-defense.
Is that basing your behavior on how the other person >> Okay.
We're not talking about physically violent actions. We're >> just
watching a guy get assassinated. What do you mean we're not talking
about physical violence? >> Are you calling for physical
violence? I don't think you are. >> I'm saying I'm saying
that it's not the same when you're responding to another >> He
literally is. He literally is. He objectively is. He's like overtly
calling for violence to be done. He's overtly calling for and
uh eagerly awaiting the expectation or the outcomes of actual
violence >> person. I'm responding to the Republicans.
That's not the same who has done physical violence to you that
you are responding to
>> to me per I guess I hope that I survive my assassination
attempt so I can come back and go look uh look wick. I told >> I
will I will I will I will hold your hand as you bleed out and
I will say you were right, Destiny. You were right all along.
And that will be the last word you hear. >> This is not
I this can't be a serious >> Of course, that was >> Wick's
still trying even in the hypothetical world where Destiny's bleeding
out, Wick still wants to be friends. Wick Wick can still save
him. Okay, Wick can still save him. >> Not a serious response.
I was joking. But what I what I am not joking about, what I am
serious about is that this idea, right, that the rhetoric is
is going to
ultimately lead to some kind of physical altercation between
the right and the left is something that the right is